hello welcome to this video playing FC
in the 2510 Puli on the ice is seem I
don't have a particular opening idea I
think I'm going for I benoni hear
something else yeah let's play the
modern benoni i think i have absolutely
never played the Benoni in this kind of
move water and tournament chess allowing
have four lines but I played the Benoni
occasionally when the night was on f3
already or against early g3 system where
it is considered to be a little bit more
solid let's say and playable without
such precise knowledge
so these six gather next to move some
very crucial why decides what set up to
go for I can play for f40 and f3 and
various setups based on an idea three
the nighttime three information ok I'm
going with a six hoping for a form so
that i get in Bishop g4 it's usually
viewed as an accomplishment if the black
and Bishop promisee eight is getting
traded there is one very sharp move now
Queen to you too ok he didn't go for
that ok I had two possibilities I can
now yeah I think I'll take immediately
black and also trying to wait for why to
play age three but I rather take
immediately and make sure that I trade
the bishop against the night
Bishop f4 us maybe a move preventing and
uh huh preventing in early 97 hmm ok I
think night be 27 s is good anyway
himself of course Bishop g5 cannot be a
bad move it was just not something that
I had expected yeah thankee castles
modern benoni is an opening where you've
really absolutely Castle short all the
time I mean both sides it's simply yeah
there's almost no scenario imaginable
where one side would want to cast long
okay that play age 6 now he has to
retreat the Bishop to e3 f4 or something
okay let's start with this move it fits
into the general setup and it allows the
95 rules in all cases i was thinking h6
Bishop f4 okay if I go h6 now where is
he going to e3 I guess I was thinking
that the night if five could be
interesting so impossible night shift
form there's also create a five queen
bee for whenever the bishop moves early
in the Benoni set up and it's tempting
to go for a night and sorry for Queen
Saudis to make some pressure on the
queenside yeah this kind of position is
definitely okay for black if you get to
trade that c8 Bishop against the night
in the classical system you're normally
in decent shape at least decent shape
okay he goes back
that's probably a good idea Queen before
now looks decidedly and sound Silla
whenever should come 95 I mean 95 yeah
midnight b5 was just well leads nowhere
I go back to the aid and he has to go
back to see 30 ok I was thinking that
night see for now should be pretty good
and okay it looks tricky be too which
was the tech down in general that's a
pretty pretty strong night
yeah I wonder if Knight g4 is good
threatening night III and Bishop deform
I mean he doesn't have any meaningful
night discoveries it just looks good
what can you do 93 and Bishop t4 are now
in this
by the way currently I'm the highest
rated 2510 player with an active account
they had one person with 2,100 something
that I had played in earlier games but
he got banned for cheating it's really
amazing how many people cheat on those
chest platforms but what is the purpose
okay so i can check first mmm yeah i
think i can check first check looks like
i'm winning in exchange take here and
have night f2 coming up
yeah maybe at the end he scotch night
see for posing technical problems but
anyway I had to take on the to him there
was no I mean this was nothing to to
think about ok so I'm going to take the
Queen now and then when they exchange 9
f 2 we has to take the exchange 94 mean
ok I go group the eighth and cover it's
it's not some technical if you have to
be after still win this position now so
I mean b5 is not a bad move by the way
check right okay i think i'll take the
exchange it takes quite a long time for
very um yeah clear and forced moves but
it's not i mean this is not a computer
officer it just takes this time
sometimes a long long time yeah
long time spend on obvious moves
indicates engine abuse but that's it's
clearly not the case here he's just an
exchange down here even though as I said
it's not it's not like completely simple
to win if he goes a five I mean he has
to play a five no he didn't do it I
think this is a mistake well get it's an
interesting move still it's not
completely rubbish or anything but I
think b5 was far more critical I have to
ship t4 next I guess or directly b5 be 5
96 95
no I think you should have played a five
and freeze them freeze the green side of
course this is still something that you
will continue 96 rookie 595 you can play
this position of course and try to try
to hang on
ja 96 so only move that I think it puts
up some kind of resistance might be five
so after that I could trade ropes but
loopy age looks better I guess okay 96
rupee 2nite c4 kind of embarrassing
it's a full exchange though
yeah what's the what's the best way if
technically I can trade this rook if I
trade the rook and then Britt bishop or
we're at 25 King Audie seven and then I
get to maneuver the rook that should
winner should win okay but that Sh a
crook be eight again quickly night 83
hmm that doesn't feel right okay jack so
I'm gyrating one Roku
yeah and I'd like to get the bishop bag
ok so that's a very direct way to do it
I mean okay d 7 ok i might get in d 7 I
bishops not not ideally placed here I
would like to get it to e5 but this is
taking ages still going to do it
so back here d7 king is 77 should still
be winning
there is no way that well here if he
wants to promote he has to put the
Bishop of the knight on c6 and I don't
think he's able to do that while at the
same time keeping the porn protected
I'm going to prevent any teen year for
yeah that's a very quickly played game
for 25 10 but most of the time I felt my
moves were pretty clear yeah this is the
thing but I get to play rock d 7 I think
next I can also go back this is not bad
and then sacrifice or just sacrifice
immediate lame
OC going nite ch that looks really crazy
but maybe that is not good that's good
that's not good is going there funny
sorry got a slight cold and after a day
of work my voice is kind of chat dettori
ating okay
yeah Bishop c6 back I guess
I don't see don't see an alternative
here I came let's get this majority
going
and you okay I go there so what is the
quickest way to do this here yeah g4 and
then f4 I guess my rook is stopping that
porn pretty reliably
you have two points it's a bit much
yeah not sure about my technical player
but it was probably enough and
sufficient waiting check yeah this is
going to promote g 3g to unavoidable
let's check sir quicker no check it
should be the quickest white resigns
okay so when I have a look here there
was a good opening position out of the
Benoni I think up to hear it was all
very standard I'm not sure about this
this- moment this is helping white that
fianchetto i mean that that all looks
kind of kind of normal 95 and therefore
i don't think f-4s is right him he
should take some kind of precaution
anticipating night see for Queenie to
one and all cognitive or be three
something like that somehow
acknowledging that this move is coming I
know this is simply did she simply
ignored it and this is already tricky b2
is hanging and I mean even taking on d 2
is a strategically quite desirable for
me the engine gives Bishop see one here
that's no surprise i think this is what
you should do adhere this is already
very dangerous okay yeah the engine just
says Niger for black wins and no no big
surprise there check this okay so I mean
there are a couple of alternatives by
the way the computer wants to do this is
quite interesting it's also pretty
strong check
and now something like this yeah that's
it's also very very good check ok I am
get the check interesting is that this
is also given as a good move by the
engine full-scale invasion yeah ok this
is really nice this is falling so queen
bee three probably and then back yeah
it's pretty awful that Center is falling
apart this is why I was a bit skeptical
about Bishop g2 and f4 and so on it's
often just um yeah to loosening in a way
ok this harem Jack yeah and I think I
mean I could have done better I am this
is this is not I mean if he goes a five
now this is not a simple technical task
no ok i will put this bishop here maybe
f6 king of several but how exactly do i
win it's not so clear how i win I mean I
cannot move the beep horn and probably
have to find some way to open up the
rooks by means of f5 or g5 or something
on the Kings side and it's got a pretty
decently coordinated position so this is
not an easy win and I think this helped
helped a lot actually just take the
material and I think the route trade was
a simple way to do it maybe not the
absolute best way but a good way yeah
yeah I think I have good control over
the position
and advance the Kings side he's not
getting anywhere with the deep on ya
around here it gets it gets absolutely
impossible to to defend yeah modern
benoni is an interesting opening one key
point is really that I got in that that
early trade here it's normally quite
beneficial for black because that bishop
on c8 as you can see by the pawn
structure it's not having a bright
future it's not doing anything on d7
ever e6 is covered f5 is covered and
g-form well quite often white plays even
aged three year and the bishop is
sitting on CA the whole time so it was
nice that I got that in and one
interesting move after Bishop g4 as the
move cretu threatening or intending a
very quickly fire it's surprisingly
interesting that move it's not quite
sure what black is playing there I think
you can take f3e but then GTX I think
pretty unclear stuff pretty unclear
stuff okay I hope you enjoyed the game
thanks for watching